they are good and we talk about the
chiefs because tyree kill sammy watkins
travis kelsey tight end but basically
receiver demarcus robinson a very
confident target for patrick mahomes and
then nicole hardman the guy they drafted
in round two this year has been a great
return specialist but also great as a
receiver and then the 49ers yeah
they haven't been passing much so we
aren't paying attention to the likes of
emmanuel sanders right and debo samuel
and and george kittle as a pass catcher
we think of him now as a blocker he's
had some huge games this year the 49ers
have weapons if and when they choose to
throw they do they're explosive of that
position you know yeah they use their
receivers a little bit in a different
light or fashion than the kansas city
chiefs but you know we have we got to
witness those guys in person first off
like when you when you talk about the
49ers wide receivers depot samuel
he's a wide receiver in a running backs
body and that's why
you can guarantee shanahan yeah he's
gonna try to throw him the ball and
throwing the ball over the middle
because he's so physical and has that
fearlessness we talked about but he's
gonna get a few carries i mean i would
be shocked if we don't see that toss
reverse we've seen or a few tosses or
speed sweeps whatever it is just to get
debo samuel the ball and uh it's again
another way shanahan keeps people off
his run game and keeps you honest in the
past game everything about it but i i
certainly feel like the 49ers receivers
have been slighted in the whole
conversation and
i don't know why i just i have a feeling
you know i know why when you're not
throwing the football yeah you're not
going to talk about the receivers well
no you're right but i was going to say
like i don't know why i just i have a
gut feeling with
you know just all the attention on the
49ers run game and i would imagine
coming out early in the game everybody
in kansas city's coaching staff is
probably thinking a lot like tony dungy
is or the general public to a degree
like hey you're going to stop the 49ers
run game and i would think shanahan's
going to have a few things you know
fail-safe plans and and such as to uh
combat the over-aggressive style and
scheme that spagnula might bring to the
table as far as stopping that run game
to where
i think we're gonna see more jimmy g
passing in this game than i think we're
we're expecting that's that's awesome
how many attempts what you're ever under
yeah when i say that to him like i'm
going to say
i i think we're going to see somewhere
between 20 and 25 and 30 attempts wow
yeah wow i do i could see a game where
maybe he's like 20 for 28 or somewhere
in that range you know it's not going to
be opening up we're in the shotgun and
things like that but i wouldn't you know
i wouldn't be surprised if we came out
in this football game in like 10 out of
the first 15 plays or pass plays that
shanahan's designed he goes oh man let
me get my guy in a rhythm i've talked
about him a lot with these plays the
night before the game the meetings like
the first ten and all that to where he
can also feel comfortable and trust you
know jimmy g to go i've thoroughly
coached him on these plays and these are
slam dunks and i've made it really
apparent to him like you throw it to
this guy or throw it out or it's from
one to two and you throw it out of
bounds whatever it may be
i i feel like you might see a curveball
that way kendrick bourne's a guy we
haven't discussed he was the most
impactful receiver so far in the
postseason because before the 49ers
shifted to run game almost exclusively
bourne had touchdown reception first
score of the game against the vikings he
had two other key catches on third down
in that game and he actually caught the
last pass before kyle shanahan decided
you know that was kind of a close call
there board made a great play on it
let's just run the ball and run the ball
and 16 runs later the game was over
you're right he is the guy we don't talk
about and he is he's been a big part of
the offense really
last seven eight nine games of the year
uh where he really you know seemed to
get the trust of jimmy garoppolo and
shanahan likes him
and and again that's the other element
you know we'll see i i think we could
this game this i think the thing that's
so fascinating to me is
i feel like it can go so many different
ways that's where like last year
yeah i wasn't expecting 13-3 game but i
didn't think it was going to be an
offensive explosion type of football
game like this year i feel like we could
see
41-38 we might say 21-7 20-17 you know i
just feel like there's so many different
ways it can go and because of the
offensive coordinators and reid and
shanahan i just feel like there's going
to be things we're not expecting in
their offensive game plans that are
going to just throw us all off i think
if the 49ers try
to deliberately slow the game down
offensively and play that deep
shell
force the chiefs to be deliberate too
that that's that's going to keep it
close and it's going to keep it low
scoring if that's the theory that they
proceed with and i'm fascinated by the
possibility we were talking about this
earlier that andy reid will decide it's
time
to basically switch it up dramatically
and run the ball right and if they're
going to be out there programmed to try
to stop the pass and they're going to be
playing deep zones and if they can pop
through that first level because those
those defensive linemen are thinking
we've got to get to patrick mahomes you
know and the the rpos yeah it was coach
dungy that mentioned how critical the
rpo is going to be in this game right
that if you do give patreon homes that
ability because it's the the whole
purpose of the rpo
is to continue the guessing game for the
defense sure run versus pass right as
long as possible and get them to commit
to a run before you decide to pass or to
a pass before you decide that would be a
very powerful weapon it definitely can
uh yeah yeah i think that would be a
weapon for the kansas city chiefs and
and then to your point too with like the
pass rush and the run game you know
you're right and that's why again i go
back to like i i what i expect from this
game is
to see things that i don't expect and
you know
a great way to slow down a fearsome pass
rush is to have different run plays
where for lack of getting too technical
a lot of what i would call draw plays
like draws where it kind of looks like a
pass the tackles let the defensive ends
fly up field right and then mahomes kind
of for one or two steps like i'm
dropping back and then it's oh here you
go damien williams i think there could
be some run plays that way with the
kansas city chiefs where they kind of
make it look like a pass at set hut and
now oh deford both so they're all going
we got to get to mahomes and you lose
your gaps in the run game integrity and
now it's oh yep we're not passing it i'm
sprinting out to the left but i gave it
to damien williams and now he's cutting
up the middle and you guys have parted
because you're in pass rush mode i
wouldn't i would be shocked if we don't
see a few of those runs from the kansas
city chief
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports